yes
bring them in hey there is hey Josh
take a seat Thanks so you excited you
were directing the new Fantastic Four
movie we are so excited yeah it's great
now I'm super pumped just a couple more
days when we start shooting this thing
great great well that's why we wanted to
bring you in here before you head off to
Louisiana to begin production what's
going on
well the thing is we have some
last-minute changes yeah just a minor
change inside no big deal we wanna start
right here go ahead and take a look wait
where's the action sequence with the
thing where's the scene with Duman
Richard's why is the ending changed
there were some budgetary concerns so we
had to pull some scenes especially the
bigger action sequences also we had to
cut back on the visual effects budget as
well well this changes the whole movie I
mean I got to start shooting this thing
a couple days what am I supposed to do
don't don't worry you'll figure it out
you're creative everything will be fine
so this isn't good eight percent on
Rotten Tomatoes eight percent don't
blame you for this but I have to what do
you have to say for yourself well listen
to these reviews Fantastic Four is so
boring they should have called it
fantastic bore it's like they forgot to
put any action in it the visual effects
were atrocious
you would think iMovie that cost over a
hundred million would have put some
money into this trainwreck
so at least it looked like a good
looking trainwreck but look you got
again
a hundred million where was the money
Josh I mean like literally where was the
money Josh look guys you guys were the
ones that changed I'm not done I'm going
on here the ending to Fantastic Four was
so rushed and terrible that it was like
they took a big crap in the middle of
the theater and then ran out as fast as
possible to avoid taking any blame for
the stench of failure what did you do
Josh it's like you just murdered all of
the babies and the kittens in the world
that's what you did I had a nice three
years old shot ourselves after seeing
this movie well your nightmares can't
blame you nightmares now and you didn't
even see this movie guys we are so
disappointed in you we thought you had a
vision for this movie and we believed in
you so just just go just bye Josh see
you later Josh hopefully forever fine
jackass look at it you know what I mean
I don't think I can look at it what kind
of a name is drink anything right please
yeah I mean destined for failure I can
tell you that I know it's German for
Justin fulfilling exactly
what is thy bidding my master is it done
then yes my master the Fantastic Four is
tanking at the box office and critical
reviews are mercilessly brutal what now
my master X you must convince the other
studio executives to halt all plans for
a sequel they will join us or die make
sure this is the case it shall be done
my master excellent
my plan for reacquiring the rights to
the Fantastic Four is working welcome
home Spidey you're happy to be back
you're next Wolverine smell like mommy
it's kind of so good so so much money
you have no idea
yeah do you feel this office my knees
three years old shot herself good whoa
whoa way Wow
okay I'm thirsty Josh my nephew murder
has nightmares about this movie it was
all your home even see them wow you are
living responsibility is Lippe
he's a failure and he's living for his
water he's not getting anyone